Unreal Engine 5's Static Mesh Editor allows you to view and edit the properties of any
static meshes that you have imported or downloaded from the FAB marketplace.
Inside of this editor, you can do things like enable Nanite, adjust LOD settings, or adjust
collision settings, and even add sockets or disable properties that affect how the static
mesh is rendered.
You can also look at mesh properties such as vertex colors, the pivot, and even the
normals.
Let's take a look at this inside the Engine now.
Now to access this tool, all we need to do is simply double click on any static mesh.
Once we do that, it will automatically open up that mesh inside of the Static Mesh Editor,
and then we can edit its properties on the right hand side underneath the Details panel.
Some other things to note here are the properties that we see on the left hand side.
This can give us information such as our triangles, vertices, UV channels, and approximate size.
We can also view our UVs, our collision, and should we want to adjust the pivot of this
by enabling the modeling tools.
We can also re-import or re-import this mesh with dialogue, which allows us to re-import
this mesh with new settings.
Finally, the Save button allows us to save any of the settings that we have adjusted
over here, ensuring that this will be saved to disk so that when we reopen this tool or
use this asset in another location, those settings have been saved and applied.